da un progettista che si occupa di
innovazione di prodotto credo che ci si
immagini che parli di futuro io invece
vorrei fare con voi un piccolo
esperimento ma solo per una manciata di
minuti quindi tranquilli vorrei portarvi
nel passato ho rifatto all'indietro di
50 60 anni più o meno alla mia data di
nascita e io sono classe 2014 anno
interessante perché in quello stesso
anno dal punto di vista dell'innovazione
venne proposto il primo cellulare con
una tecnologia capace di auto una
batteria capace di autoalimentarsi è un
prodotto molto costoso quindi di lusso
costava circa quanto lo stipendio
mensile di un manager e nello stesso
anno per coincidenza era uscita la prima
automobile totalmente stampata in stampa
digitale
quindi vediamo una delle fasi di stampa
che lo chassis si chiamava strati e la
mitica per noi italiani divenne mitica
perché io ero appena nata perché era
stata anche progettata aveva un nome
italiano anche se i produttori erano una
di quelle micro fabbriche che negli
stati uniti già stavano operando erano
anzi l'azienda pioniera in questo campo
nel produrre con la tecnologia digitale
automobili spesso e aggiustando le cose
che capiamo come le cose funzionano
scriveva qualche anno prima nel 2008
richard sennet nel suo l'uomo artigiano
un libro che consiglio a tutti di
leggere ma che a me serve qui soltanto
per ricordarci che quelli erano gli anni
nel quale c'era si era compiuto quel
giro di boa che significava il passaggio
da una cultura meccanica seguitemi in
questo nella quale gli oggetti per
quanto complessi erano alcuni
dunque composti di parti che in qualche
modo erano riconoscibili a una cultura
elettronica nel quale invece complessità
miniaturizzazione e una serie di eventi
che in parte vedremo insieme oggi
avevano portato a rendere gli oggetti
sempre più facili da utilizzare ma
sempre meno comprensibili nel come erano
fatti e in quegli stessi anni invisibile
piuttosto silenziosa mattia anche una
rivolta che a me oggi piace chiamare la
rivolta degli smontatori perché era una
rivolta che era partita nelle azioni
degli attivisti sociali di quartiere che
in qualche modo volevano riappropriarsi
del destino degli oggetti che erano dati
che era dato di utilizzare cioè quelli
dell'elettronica ma aveva avuto un
moltiplicatore virale si dice via
internet attraverso le comunità dei più
giovani che erano invece abituati a
lavorare online ea scambiarsi
informazioni online come dei nuovi
apprendisti tranquilli
per fortuna siamo nel 2014 non siamo nel
2060 perché nessuno di noi sa che cosa
accadrà veramente nel futuro il futuro
certe volte un pochino ci spaventa non
sappiamo esattamente cosa potrà
succedere domani ma possiamo cogliere
nel presente di oggi dei segni di
cambiamento che vi qualche modo
potrebbero essere dei semi di futuro
possiamo anche prendere lezioni dall
esperienza del passato pur che siamo
disposti a ri attualizzarle e allora è
qui che vi vorrei portare un pochino
dentro queste ipotesi del che cos'è che
divide il presente di oggi da un domani
dove probabilmente avere cura delle cose
manutenerla ripararle farle durare a
lungo potrebbe diventare qualcosa di più
o meno simile a una tranquilla
indiscussa
anzi forse necessaria normalità e della
domanda che io mi sono fatto
me la sono fatta perché lavoro con i
prodotti lavoro con le aziende per
cercare di capire se era vero dei
segnali che coglievo appunto in questa
rete appunto in questo mondo delle
innovazioni che la domanda di
riparabilità in qualche modo per varie
vicende era in crescita e se questa
crescita dovuta ai protagonisti che la
volevano in qualche modo riportare in
campo stava cambiando inaspettatamente
ancora sotterranea i destini degli
oggetti in qualche modo il modo con il
quale produciamo progettiamo produciamo
e poi usiamo gli oggetti e quindi siamo
andati a guardare
io con il mio studio perché questa
ricerca è assolutamente autofinanziata
ma che ha ricevuto il patrocinio
dell'adi cioè l'associazione del design
industriale italiano come dire andiamo
avanti a capire che cosa succede
abbiamo guardato un po a tutti non
solamente ai designer o agli
imprenditori più visionari non solamente
agli scienziati non solo agli innovatori
manco a tutti e quindi anche agli attori
quali siano gli attori sociali e così ci
siamo accorti che perlomeno è già
accaduto che l'idea di ritornare a
pensare a come le cose sono fatte e un
fatto già intragenerazionale lenta
culturale cosa vuol dire questo vuol
dire che i paesi di crescita quando
introducono delle nuove tecnologie
trovano del tutto naturale anzi
necessario istruire i propri tecnici
propri ingegneri a costruire e
manutenere e poi sapere riparare nel
tempo nei propri villaggi di origine le
tecnologie che hanno installato e intra
generazionale perché in un momento molto
particolare in cui chi è uscito magari
troppo presto dal mondo del lavoro ed è
ancora quella generazione ricchissima di
tante abilità manuali ha incominciato
proprio così nelle atmosfere di
quartiere che qualcuno oggi ci ha fatto
rivivere ha incominciato a mettere a
disposizione i suoi saperi
del fare per riparare il tostapane ma ha
fatto un passo in più l'ha condiviso con
i più giovani perché i più giovani
invece che nel mondo del lavoro ancora
non sono entrati sono abituati simi a
usare la tecnologia sono abituate a
usare l'elettronica di consumo e sanno
anche che questi oggetti sono
costosissimi quindi per loro scambiarsi
informazioni e vitale a capire come
fargli usare anche un lungo possibile e
questo ha fatto entrare questa realtà
questo è un pochino più inaspettato
nella pancia delle aziende
una di queste repair community londinese
oggi fa dei corsi di formazione per i
bandi per le banche londinesi o per
multinazionali dell'information
technology perché all'interno di una
politica di welfare aziendale e
interessante far capire ai propri
dipendenti da di coscienza della
tecnologia che stanno utilizzando ma il
fai da te 2.0
chiamiamolo così tanto per dire che sono
dei nuovi apprendisti che sono dei nuovi
artigiani più lungimirante e anche più
abile più serio più approfondito in
realtà mettendo in piedi le proprie
guide online per la riparazione di
qualunque cosa alla quale danno il
contributo gli utenti della rete
spiegando facendo riprovando con la
costruzione dei loro utensili bellissimi
da un punto di vista del design anche se
non sono designer sono ingegneri
informatici e così precisi con una
precisione chirurgica che non solo
diventano il modo per denunciare il
fatto che una semplice vite fino a ieri
oggi è diventato un modo per non farci
entrare all'interno degli oggetti quindi
costruiscono gli utensili per renderlo
possibile
ma più che è un aspetto pratico il vero
cambiamento che loro stanno portando e
che ci stanno spostando verso un mondo
nuovamente verso un mondo materiale
che avevamo in parte dimenticato e
quindi hanno aperto l'immaginazione
allora la pratica del riparare del
riparare dinamico si dice oggi ci porta
in realtà la libertà e anche la voglia
di capire un po meglio come le cose sono
fatte e quindi è molto vicina a farci
porre delle domande a chi progetta e a
chi produce di ripensare perlomeno alla
logica con il quale le cose vengono
prodotte questi signori si sono
guadagnate una tale autorevolezza che le
aziende più lungimiranti semplicemente
che vogliono dare qualche cosa di più
interessante di più nuovo ai propri
utilizzatori o che magari all'interno di
politiche di responsabilità sociale o
ambientale
vogliono essere più efficaci sul piano
dell'uso cioè dopo il momento del
consumo stanno utilizzando questi
signori e la loro esperienza per
costruire anche dei servizi sul prodotto
per cambiare i prodotti mentre si stanno
sviluppando per esempio rendendoli più
riparabili così oggi ci troviamo con
delle guide online dentro i siti dei
produttori magari di abbigliamento
outdoor non un prodotto alta tecnologia
come il cellulare ma questa cultura dei
maker sta portando anche un paio di
altri suggerimenti alle aziende che
forse vanno un pochino più osservati per
esempio forse alcuni di voi che qui che
sono studenti ne avranno sentito
sicuramente parlare
accanto al download della musica oggi
possiamo fare il download del design che
vuol dire che possiamo scaricarci dei
file si dice delle matematiche diciamo
noi tecnici in realtà di fatto dei
disegni se poi siamo anche capaci di
intervenire su questi disegni o anche se
non lo siamo
possiamo poi andare nel server sotto
casa che ha una stampante digitale
stamparci piccoli pezzi quindi in senso
positivo si sta aprendo l'idea che
potremmo fare il download e ricambi se
tutte queste innovazioni entrassero
stanno entrando in questo presente di
domani nel dna dei prodotti e anche
restando vicino a una cultura del
riparare in qualche modo del
interessarci anche di cosa succede dopo
significano almeno due cose che tutto
diventa più flessibile il prodotto è più
flessibile e che tutto diventa più
partecipativo stanno nascendo prodotti
più accessibili
sì questo non vuol dire soltanto che ci
posso andare dentro per toglierli dei
componenti vuol dire magari che posso
cambiare una parte fisica del prodotto
quando mi serve senza chiedere
l'assistenza specializzata nei prodotti
aggiornabili il passo è breve
a quel punto perché cambiare il mio
cellulare soltanto prima avevo solo una
fotocamera olio voglio una videocamera
cambio il pezzo e gliela metto e questo
potremmo farlo anche nelle lavatrici
nelle lavastoviglie o magari avere una
stampante che diventano all'ala
stoviglie sembra anche questo futuro ma
in realtà per esempio in alcune
università australiane quest'esperienza
con la xerox già si sta facendo e poi
che forse più interessante e ci piace di
più portare l'attenzione su questo se
guardiamo così tanto ai nuovi riparatori
dei prodotti più semplificati eh sì dice
bello facciamo semplice nella epoca
meccanica fare semplice
era un'operazione oggi lo è in termini
diversi certo la semplificazione non è
solo in termini fisici non escono solo
solo prodotti più semplici ad aprire
sono anche prodotti più semplici perché
sono più trasparenti quindi prodotti più
etici e allora questo mondo della
riparazione della nuova riparazione sta
aprendo un potenziale di innovazione
molto interessante che va dai chimici
che studiano materiali che sono autori
paranti ma anche sul piano delle
poetiche si stanno rimettendo in campo
delle nuove estetiche e queste sfide si
saldano poi con chi sta pensando a delle
produzioni etiche e sostenibili e quindi
in qualche modo vuole dare un contributo
una svolta sul piano del consumo a tutte
queste innovazioni fantastiche
l'entusiasmo
abbiamo per le innovazioni per la
tecnologia per le storica per il
digitale insomma per quelli internet
delle cose ci potrebbe in realtà portare
anche a un accorciamento del tempo che
passa tra la fascinazione e la noia
e poi ci sono i numeri sempre nel 2014
bellissimo chi è nato questo anno
pensione autunno
siamo diventati 7.2 miliardi di persone
nella terra e ma un altro dato che non
si conosce così tanto è che siamo stati
superati dalle sim
cioè ci sono più accessi mobili credo
7.2 e 7 accessi mobili nel mondo che
persone
e allora se nel 2060 ci dicono che
saremo 9 miliardi di persone sicuramente
entro il secolo tra i 10 e gli 11
miliardi di persone
noi abbiamo davanti un iperbole nei
termini del consumo o una parabola anche
perché alcuni aspetti come la
personalizzazione di massa che la stampa
digitale ci mette dall'altra ci può
risolvere nelle problematiche funzionali
ad personam
però allo stesso tempo potrebbe far
aumentare la stupidità cioè quell
entusiasmo un po stupido che porta
subito alla noia che ci fa costruire gli
oggetti che vogliamo quando vogliamo
poco importa se dopo 10 minuti
non ci interessano più allora andiamo un
po al passato perché noi abbiamo un
eredità che il design italiano le
fabbriche italiane del design e questa
frase di achille castiglioni che dice
più o meno
vabbè prima di capire cosa dobbiamo fare
capiamo invece cosa non dobbiamo fare
lui la diceva più o meno negli anni 60
ad oggi cosa possiamo fare quale può
essere veramente il contributo del
design
quello che davvero dobbiamo
riattualizzare noi come progettisti i
produttori e gli utilizzatori e il senso
del rispetto perché la cultura della
riparazione o comunque diciamo la meglio
la cultura del fare
che riporta l'attenzione sulla cultura
del fare è qualcosa che in fondo ci
riporta a un'idea di rispetto per il
fare che è stata tutta la nostra cultura
scientifica e umanistica dal settecento
illuminista che siamo all'asilo pedini
leader o e la la merkel ha proprio la
nostra cultura europea
fino all'altro ieri ma se riusciamo
soltanto a riportare in qualche modo
rispetto nel come sono fatte le cose
perché sulle eccellenze del fare è
giocata la qualità delle cose ma
soprattutto è giocata la qualità alta
quella che il paradosso del lusso ci ha
fatto perdere un po troppo di vista ma
anche un rispetto per altre dimensioni
del fare che sono legate per esempio
alla pazienza alla costanza nel tempo e
poi il rispetto per la bellezza che ho
sentito citare prima mi ha veramente
dato energia
ma per quale bellezza beh per lo meno
rispetto per la sua non banalizzazione
perché la bellezza è un valore non è un
prezzo e allora non so quanti di voi
usciti di qui andranno a guardare
levitin e del proprio ultimo modello 6
non diciamo di quale marca per scoprire
che non solo sono piccole ma sono penta
lobate quindi non lo trovate l'utensile
per aprirle se non comprate dai
riparatori della ifixit ma forse anche
ripensano che questo verbo riparare che
si dice allo stesso modo in tutte le
principali lingue europee quindi in
tutte le lingue del nostro benedetto
occidente industrializzato deriva ha una
matrice latina che la matrice della
nostra lingua italiana che era a rare e
quindi ci ricorda che in fondo non è
tanto una questione solo materiale non
si tratta solo di rimettere a posto di
rimediare significa anche saper e
difendere
cioè in qualche modo ridare valore a
come sono fatte le cose perché le cose
che sono state fatte le abbiamo dovute
produrre noi